[Musique]
Nassima dandar présidente du département
a reçu ce jeudi 25 août la délégation de
l'association de sé food se rendant au
Jeux Paralympique de Rio au Brésil
accompagné de leur famille des
encadrants les cinq sportifs réunionnaés
ont présenté les actions mises en place
par leur association j'ai souhaité les
rencontrer il il demandaient seulement
qu'on puisse un peu les les accompagner
et donc on leur souhaite non seulement
bonne chance mais on va essayer vraiment
d'aider cette grande famille de joueurs
ce sont des professionnels mais qui
portent le sport dans leur cœur avant de
porter sur eux un un handicap et donc
franchement je voulais les féliciter
l'association s food de la Réunion est
basée à Saint-Denis ces objectifs sont
de réaliser développer et péréniser les
actions en faveur d'une meilleure
autonomie et insertion par le sport des
personnes déficientes visuelles alors c
finon c'est une association qui a été
créée en octobre 2013 c'est du football
pour aveugle en fait c'est développer
péréniser la pratique du sport pour les
personnes déficientes visuelle à la
Réunion et dans le se indien on a créé
en fait un centre de préformation sur
tenu par l'unad union nationale des
aveugles de de Bordeaux pour pouvoir en
fait former des aveugles pour jouer au
cifute au football pour aveugles et et
l'idée c'était de partir à Rio pour
rencontrer en fait les les meilleurs
joueurs français les meilleurs joueurs
mondiaux l'idée partir un petit peu de
ce de cette volonté là et de ce un peu
ce rêve là un peu fou tout d'abord une
escale à Paris avec la rencontre du
champion de France de cess foot Gael
rivière et du parrain de cette
discipline Thomas fontaine joueur
professionnel à ClermontFerrand puis ce
sera le grand départ pour Rio où ils
participeront à la cérémonie d'ouverture
des Jeux le 7 septembre
l'accomplissement d'un rêve pour ses
joueurs et leur famille on profite
autant autant que joueur on profite du
projet c'est un projet qu'on attend avec
patience si on a bien profité de faire
de dîner danscant pour marquer un bon
projet donc on serait bien content
d'arriver là-bas pour moi ça représente
une confirmation de notre statut là où
on est à l'heure actuelle de ce qu'on a
pu accomplir jusqu'à jusqu'à jusqu'à
jusqu'àaujourd'hui et ça montre aussi
que bah quand on peut quand on veut on
peut en se donnant les moyens on se
donnant les moyens on l' réaliser sans
problème il faut qu'il réalise S il fa
il faut que il voit il voit autre chose
je vais pas les laisser partir tout seul
donc j'y vais avec lui et puis
je je serai près de lui au mois de
décembre ils s'envoleront en Guadeloupe
et feront rayonner cette discipline dans
ce département
[Musique]
toutreem